[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum i hope you're having a
great week
uh weekend whenever you're listening to
this i hope you're uh
subscribed and if this is your first
episode because you're a maggie lawson
fan which we all are
i hope you'll subscribe and listen every
week because we've got a lot of great
guests coming up and
have had a lot of great guests and we
really get into it we talk about
life and anxiety and stress and work and
just real stuff we don't uh we don't
[ __ ] too much here we we we have fun
but we don't [ __ ] too much and uh i
have a new segment we have a new segment
here on the show
called how you doing how you doing
it's a mental health segment just how
you doing it's just how you how you
freaking doing how
are you guys doing out there hey you had
a stressful week are you
are you worried about something are you
uh
not being good to yourself what is it
ryan how are you doing how am i doing
how you doing uh we recorded a lot this
week so that was
fun but at the same time i had to go
home and and do my other work
right so it has been a little bit
stressful right that's true
but we do have weeks off where we don't
do anything really well
a lot of weeks off we did i i didn't do
podcasts for a while because we had a
lot
what they call it in the can in the can
but you're saying you were you know it
was stressful all of a sudden there's
five you're here every day or
you're doing all these podcasts you've
got to get them uploaded
so it starts and it's stress for me too
because i hadn't done them in a while so
i was like oh [ __ ] do i still have it
it's like not acting in a while and then
you just go can i still act
and uh i found out that i could still do
it i could still do it we had some
really great interviews and uh i i've
been a little stressed i've been
you know worried about things and um
uh but i try to you know and i
and i think to myself why are you
feeling this way well you haven't really
exercised this week
oh go figure you're drinking you're
eating like [ __ ] oh what what's so
there's reasons behind everything
and so for me i'm just like trying to
get back on track trying to eat better
trying to stay off the sodas
staying off the carvel ice cream
sandwich flying saucers oh my god what
are you
ten got to stay off the top of that
that's a true question my friend
um but uh how are you doing guys i hope
you're doing well out there i hope
you're hanging in there i know we're uh
we're seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel here with the pandemic and i hope
you guys are being responsible and good
to yourselves and loving yourselves so
that's uh that's how you doing so we
just checked in with me and ryan and
checking in with you we're also going to
check in um
eventually with the guests even though
this was pre-recorded so yeah we can't
do that it's a new segment
uh if you want to uh subscribe to the
podcast it's easy you just go to
the uh on youtube ryan uh youtube.com
inside of you with michael rosenbaum
baum
that's correct and you can go on apple
you can just spotify
there's all sorts of things apple yeah
you can listen to the show
watch it on youtube i think you'll enjoy
it if you watch it on youtube and spread
the word we really encourage you to
spread the word the handles on instagram
are at inside of you podcast on
instagram and facebook
and at insideypod on the tweeter you
could also go to the merch store
the inside of you online store and you
can get
not only inside of you mugs autograph
mugs hats but you can get
smallville stuff you can get a small box
i think i have some funko pop
lex luthor's left some lex luthor
pictures just a bunch of stuff it's a
fun little site inside of you online
store
and if you'd like anything from the band
my band sunspin go to sunspin.com
and you could buy shirts hats you can
get zooms with me and rob
um you could book the band you could do
all that stuff but we got a lot of great
merch
and uh you could do that uh this this
guest
maggie is such a sweetheart and um
i talked to her co-stars um from psych
and they adored her so i always wanted
to get her on the podcast and um
she's not like me where she just is an
open book she likes to kind of keep
things close to the vest and
so i get it i understand it but she did
open up she talked about her divorce she
talked about life she talked about psych
she talked about a lot of things
and it was really interesting and she's
a very likable person wouldn't you say i
would agree i mean i thought this girl's
marriage material
that's what i was thinking sometimes my
guess i'm like wow this girl's awesome
this woman is awesome not this girl
this woman is awesome she is she's
really she's really really great what
did you find most interesting about her
i mean she's just super
nice it was a nice way to open up about
a lot of stuff yeah i like when people
open up you know how i like that oh yeah
let's just get right into it let's get
oh by the way before we get into it make
sure you join
patreon patreon.com inside of you i'll
write you a message it's a great big
family if you want to
help the podcast in other ways if you're
really digging it you want to get to the
podcast fine if you just uh
don't that's fine too but patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you
and let's get inside of maggie lawson
it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you
with michael
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
okay first of all hi maggie lawson
margaret margaret that is my marge
marge margaret cassidy last did you say
marge have you ever heard marge
yeah but i've never been called back do
you remember in peewee's big adventure
when he says tell him the large marge
sent you you never got that [ __ ] in high
school
never got that [ __ ] in his thank god
that would be terrible
no no i always said if like i became a
like a doctor a lawyer or something i
might go by like dr
margaret but um dr margaret lawson
you know i want to congratulate you i've
never done a pre-interview before
and uh you're the first you know
sometimes sometimes you gotta do a
pre-interview yeah sometimes you gotta
just
i get um thank you by the way for doing
that
uh just because i get uh
i i have i get a lot of anxiety talking
about myself you can probably already
sense it so
well that's probably good in in a way
because you're not so
self-involved maybe is that true i don't
know i think i'm just
painfully private really
until today yeah yeah i mean i think i'm
very social and i like being out i like
you know i like being with people and i
like sharing but i'm also
um very very very very private were your
folks private
you know yes and no i mean i think
i think in our family actually no when i
think about it there was a lot of like
very open talking very open feeling
talking
um so i'm not i i'm not really sure
where it comes from it's really
interesting like i have it's something
that has sort of developed
later um because when i was younger i
was
i was such a like i was doing musical
theater i was singing i was dancing i
was acting
i was like you know i was pretty pretty
out there
but i as i got older i don't know i've
i've been working on this
it's like um it's like i'm really
comfortable
when i have lines and a character to
play
but i get really uncomfortable if i'm
just
not uncomfortable it's probably not the
right word but just i just get really
anxious when i just have
that's normal i think a lot of people
get like that you said something a
minute ago you said
there's a lot of open feelings in your
family what does that mean open feelings
it was like
i love you margaret i love you too mom
what was that
no but i i guess what i'm trying to like
there there really wasn't uh
like a moment or a thing you know i
remember
when i say open feelings i just feel
like all topics were
sort of up for uh for discussion like
there was nothing off
limits so my my mom was always so so
great about that like she was such a
i could literally come home from school
and ask her a question about anything
sex i could literally walk in the door
and be like hey i heard this word orgasm
today
what is that and she would do her best
to sort of scientifically
explain what that is in a way that i at
nine years old or eight years old or
whatever could understand how would she
do it how would she put that
i remember in health class we had health
class in seventh grade and you had to
take it and
i didn't know what was going on in fact
i didn't get laid till many many moons
later
and i remember that my mom asked me
something now
my parents had a different way of
raising their children they would
humiliate them my f my dad mom was like
what did you learn in health i was like
i i know what's going on
and they're like what do you mean i go
sex and she's like what about it i'm
like
a man and a woman they have sex and the
guy has an organism
and she goes and she started laughing at
me and i ran upstairs and she
then i heard her friend telling her
friends organism
he said organism isn't that the cutest
oh that's so but it was
it was very private it was very private
in my family like i never saw my dad i
saw
i never saw my mom naked or my dad i saw
my mom's boobs once by
accident but i never you know everything
was
private it was really weird one time i
saw my dad's balls and it was like it
ruined me
and uh he got it yeah sorry
well he got upset he was like i was you
know i remember we're sitting there
watching tv
and i just turned and he was wearing
these little blue shorts because he went
swimming
and then i go and i just go yeah
i go dad i think your balls hanging out
of your pants he goes what
you're a pig get out of here get out of
the room go upstairs to your room
like what i'm in trouble because your
balls are hanging out of your shorts
but that's what i remember so my family
was different
yeah yeah yeah but your family you could
talk about orgasms you could talk about
anything with your
with your mother not so much your father
well yeah i think my mom sort of took
the lead on
on most of that stuff um yeah for sure
she was like
it's interesting we weren't like a super
affectionate
um family like it wasn't in a way of
like physical touch
or a lot of i love yous or any of that
but there was this
like openness about
what what like what could be put on the
table
and up for discussion which i i i have
friends now who have kids and they'll
call and they'll be like oh my god like
he's asking me about sex or he's asking
me i'm like just be
i don't know if this is the right way
but i know i greatly appreciated it
it's like just be direct and as honest
as you can be
my mom i don't know she probably said
you know it's a really excited feeling
and something happens
but it was never like talking down to or
being condescending
it was always like just on the level you
can handle it
trusting me with the information and so
so it created like a that's what i think
i mean like this sort of sense of
openness like my mom was so
so good about like not being
shocked at a question or something like
great in a crisis
wow now did she was she like very
protective in high school like
teaching you about sex and saying hey i
don't want you having sex or was she
like
it wasn't a religious family they were
more like open like they knew you were
gonna have sex use a condom sweetheart
no it wasn't necessarily like that i
have two brothers and it was
it was a bit um i think she
because i and by the time i was in high
school my my parents were
divorced and i think she really
tried to protect me even more so than my
brothers like they could get away with a
lot more and yes
i think more of the i won't say it was
disgusting it was more like expected
like
whether it was getting in trouble or
like i was such a
responsible mom like
figure in high school really yeah like i
was always the
the designated driver or yeah and i was
i was so for me what i wanted to like
i'd already started acting i already
kind of knew what i wanted to do
so for me the idea of of like
possibly having something come up
such as you know my mom was just great
at putting all the risks on the table
around sex
so it scared the [ __ ] out of me to the
point where it's like i cannot
mess this train i can't mess up this
this this train i'm on right now so and
that was all sort of like career driven
driven even in high school
so she knew exactly what to say to scare
the living [ __ ] out of me into never
doing that
she mentioned her right so i do so so it
wasn't really anything that was like
a possibility i i know she would have
been great if i
if something had happened or if i you
know all that but like
no i i think it was just sort of that's
that's off limits if
if i want to go do this uh
that can't that risk can't be a play so
you were a good girl you were the one
the designated driver you were the
were you a cheerleader in high school
you're popular no
i mean i i was not a cheerleader knew i
was uh
i was already doing plays and sort of uh
you know it's really interesting i i
started
i came out to la my sophomore year of
high school
what yeah so i it's so wild
wait a minute wait a minute wait wait
wait wait as a sophomore in high school
i mean i didn't even start puberty too
late like probably 14 or 15 years old
i could i'm so immature as as a 48 year
old dude
that if i go back to then i i
it was a timing thing i i think
everything kind of
fit like i i didn't i didn't become
really successful until you know i was
in my mid-20s
which was even early for for me i was
very immature so
i can't imagine being a sophomore in
high school coming out from louisville
kentucky
and starting an acting career did you so
your parents both approved of your
acting and
your mom took you out yeah it's such a
wild story
um tell me the wildest story
um the wildest story well
you know it went back years actually so
when i was like
i think i was 12. do you remember
showcases do you remember the showcases
that used to happen
yeah there was one that happened in
louisville and i went
and i met these showcases were these
weird things i think you
paid to go to um and
there would be like agents from
hollywood
maybe casting directors producers or
whatever you got this opportunity to go
to this seminar
and learn about la and hollywood
and maybe read a scene and they'd give
you feedback on whether or not you like
have it right i'm 12. i don't know any
better i've been doing plays for a few
years
um and i did this uh i hosted a little a
show but we'll get into that that that's
another thing but i hosted this little
show on a fox station and
kentucky and everybody was like oh you
should you should
go to this seminar and and and see what
they say
you know or whatever if there's a chance
to become a star
so i go to the seminar i read the scenes
i'm 12 years old i i'm like
okay this is fine and i get like a lot
of feedback
uh from these people this guy gives me
his card i'll get to him in a second
um i don't think anything of it my mom
and i we like we have this discussion
now keep in mind we don't have like
money this is not a situation where it
was like sure we can go to
new york and see about a career that's
actually the first place we went but
um or la this was like uh
it felt impossible but it these things
kind of popped up that made us talk
about it
so i i get this card i have this real
discussion with my mom and dad and
it's like no man i'm a kid and i want to
be a kid
and i don't want to do that and i like
my life here in kentucky and i like my
my plays and what i'm doing and and so
we just dropped it
and a couple of years later i'm doing a
play
and the director of the play was this
guy john huffman uh
who had done a lot of work in la like i
knew he went back and forth and he had a
lot of like
connections great great director and was
a great friend
and i tell him this story about this
showcase i went to a few years
uh prior and i tell him about this guy
who gave me his card
and i'm like he's like do you know i
said it was an agent and he's like do
you know
who the agent was and i said uh yeah i
think and like i get the card
i'll never forget my mom kept the card
for years in her
metallic gold cigarette holder
and it was like it had this like clear
little thing on it and it always i don't
know why
she just kept it for safekeeping i don't
know why we even kept this guy well
probably because
at that point it was it was a moment
where my daughter's talented and this
agent gave her
his card and it was a moment she didn't
know that you'd be as successful as you
were so maybe and she kept it around it
was one of the first mementos or
whatever
so john says john looks at the card and
he's like
do you know who this is i'm like no and
he's like this is like
one of the biggest agents this guy jeff
witches who
still i believe is an agent at william
morris
and he loses his mind i have no idea
what any of this means and he's like you
should call him
he's like you should call him if an
agent from from william morris gives you
his card you should call
um and so i i i make this phone call
one day and now i think i'm 14 15.
oh boy and this woman at william mars
picks up
and and you know i say can i please have
jeff witch's office
and somehow i get through to him
and i tell him the story i'm like hi my
name is maggie lawson
you gave me your card three years ago
at a showcase in louisville kentucky and
said if i ever came to la to call you
you'd take a meeting with me
and he was like okay well if i said i'd
take a meeting i'll take a meeting when
are you coming
and why that sort of put the wheels in
motion for
i i didn't realize that was just a
meeting i didn't know what any of it
meant i just knew i had a lot of people
around me telling me this was a really
big deal
and so i was like oh i guess we should
take this seriously
um so we start making the plans
to come out here um and uh
while we were doing it um this is just a
side part of the story that's very very
funny
my little brother reads this article
about um they're doing a clueless tv
series
and they were looking for at least a
silverstone look-alikes
well you you there's a brother's like
maggie you gotta go
like you're gonna get this you gotta go
so i know i know we now have in our
heads
that i i have to get to la or at least
get myself
somehow auditioning for this series
because we just didn't know any better
um and i have this meeting if i want it
with this guy
at william morris um and
and i took it was i believe my sophomore
year spring break
um every single penny we had
and my mom and i came out and i met
him and i met um
a guy in an elevator i'll never forget
it and i'm
now i'm forgetting his name but he said
he was a manager it was with my mom
probably probably creepy but uh
he put me in touch with this woman ro
diamond
who is an agent here and i call ro
off this guy's this guy had already
called her and said this girl's gonna
call you i think you should meet her
it was so bizarre michael how these all
these things sort of happen
wow i meet ro and she's like i can't
well first i have my meeting with jeff
witches who is so sweet but he's also
just like
you're so green i'm not gonna take you
on come back to me in a few years did
you mention
the clueless series to him of course i
did
which by the way was already cast and
that wasn't even a possibility anymore
um yeah i'm coming into these rooms like
hi hi i hear
they're holding auditions where can i
get my audition for for this clueless tv
series
anyway i meet with ro who's a smaller
agency she sends me to
read for a friend of hers fran bascom
who is the casting director of days of
our lives who has since passed
this woman calls row and says you know
the scenes went went well
whatever and rose like i'll represent
you if you want to come out
and ro was my agent for 10 years um
she actually got me a holding deal at
warner brothers
when they gave those out yeah kind of
yeah they used to hand them out give you
some money and put you on hold
to find your project i mean i don't know
if you can do this they never find you
anything
which by the way just to give you a clue
where my family was
that was double what my parents made in
a year
30 grand so we were literally losing our
minds like
what is happening anyway so with the
holding deal they put me in a show
and a pilot and meanwhile i'm going back
and forth
between louisville and can and uh and
and la
and trying to do school work or whatever
any anyway
and i i do this pilot that they told me
was sold for 13 on the air
so my family makes this huge decision to
to come to los angeles only to have us
uh learn when we got here they decided
to not go forward with the show so now
we're in l.a
you moved out to la to do a show that
got cancelled before you started filming
it
yeah pretty much i mean there were other
things at play like luckily during that
time i got to do
during the back and forth time i would
so while i was in la i would read for
other things
and i got to do like a guest
spot on something here there i ended up
doing this movie pleasantville
um which was like such an insane
experience
for like that was a big movie yeah it
was it was crazy it was wild like i
i had no i i had it was such it's so
wild i think back on the story now
anyway
yeah we literally packed up a um
we packed up a woody station wagon that
was not even ours it was my grandparents
we didn't own a car uh and my brother
and my mom and i drove to l.a anyway
that's how we got here
inside of you is brought to you by hello
fresh you're going to want to listen to
this because at the end i'm going to
tell you about 12
free meals including free shipping so
you might want to listen
uh with hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients
in mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right
to your door you don't go shopping and
oh my gosh was i supposed to get some
celery was i suppose no skip trips to
the grocery store and count on
hellofresh to make home cooking easy fun
and affordable and that's why it's
america's number one
meal kit you don't need me to tell you
that ryan try hello fresh's quick and
easy meals 15 to 20 minute dinners
breakfast on the go and more easy
options perfect for your busy lifestyle
get better value folks hello fresh is 28
cheaper than shopping at your local
grocery store 72 percent cheaper than a
restaurant meal
without sacrificing the quality and that
source by the way is zagat dining survey
so you know it's the truth i love this
stuff because uh
you know i feel like i'm still cooking
but i have everything right in front of
me
i know it's healthy and i know i feel
like i'm doing something that's an
accomplishment
and i can make a fresh meal right there
i feel like sometimes
these other meals that are already
together you just throw in the microwave
it doesn't it just doesn't seem like
that that's the health
and health is wealth ryan am i right
things that rhyme are true usually
things that rhyme are true it's just
it's uh you're gonna
you're gonna love doing this it's so
easy the recipes right there
the instructions i i can do this uh if
you know me which i think if you're
listening to this podcast you know me
you know that it's not easy i don't
follow instructions this is easy i can
make a meal in about 30 minutes
go to hellofresh.com
12 iou and use code 12
iou for 12 free meals including
free shipping that's hellofresh.com
12 iou and use code 12 iou
for 12 free meals including
free shipping how are you not doing this
right now
it's free inside he was brought to you
by
better help better help online therapy
you know i've talked about this therapy
means a lot to me and it helps so many
people around the world and if you're
just avoiding it avoiding it just listen
for a second
in may's mental health awareness month
and throughout june
inside of you inside of you my podcast
is proud to join the cause of
destigmatizing therapy
if you are struggling like so many
people are um
with relationships or you're having
difficulty sleeping or difficulty
meeting your goals that's that's me
you're feeling anxious or you're
stressed better help counselors can
listen
they can listen and they can help you
it's it's just a fact
talk to anybody who's had therapy i
guarantee you they're going to say
they're
better they're better because of it
better help will assess your needs
match you with your own licensed
professional you can start communicating
in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online and therapists have
a broad range of expertise that may not
be locally available in your area
but the service is available for clients
worldwide
you could text your therapist you can
call your therapist
you could facetime or whatever your
therapist you could look at them you
could hear them you could see
it's so easy and they can make it as
comfortable as you want it to be and
therapy is what you make of it
it's what you want it to be it's
different for each person if you just
got a lot on your mind
a lot of stuff bottled up therapy could
be a
wonderful wonderful thing for you i know
it's been a wonderful thing for me
all you do is log into your account
anytime you send a message to your
counselor
you can schedule weekly video phone or
even live chat sessions like i said
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors
if you need if you don't like someone
which happens sometimes
boom you get someone else it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available boy is it less expensive than
offline i have spent so much money on
that and better help is
significantly cheaper so many people
have been using betterhelp that they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy
at betterhelp.com inside
that's better h-e-l-p-com
slash inside better help
online therapy were you a
star now in louisville to the people in
your high school to people around you
like she's in la
she's got a show she's did you embellish
it come on
no i don't think so there was this part
of me that was almost like
a little shy about it like i wanted to
just go home
like i would go back and forth i mean
through my senior year i got to graduate
with
my my senior class in louisville by
doing
correspondence and so when i went home i
wanted to just be
[Music]
like i almost didn't didn't want to talk
about that all the time even though it
was the topic it was like
no i just want to go to the game or you
know
see my see my boyfriend or you know
whatever
so it was weird i was really really shy
about it at first so the show
doesn't get picked up and you decide
which is is crazy
you decide to stay we did yeah yeah
my brother was already in my younger
brother was in
high school and he found a school out
here
and and wait your whole family moved
from louisville for you to los angeles
pretty much what what how much
i mean to me though it was a family
decision that's okay
pressure though that's a lot of pressure
if you don't succeed dad doesn't have
the thirty thousand dollar job fifteen
thousand dollar job
there was no safety net there was no
savings oh my god they went all out for
you that is
love sweetie it was a lot it was a lot
it was a lot on us
it was a lot of uh really
i remember the conversations being like
so yeah it was a lot of love um but and
also
i think in a way i think all
all of us were looking
toward a better life
um just and i don't even want to say
that it was so
bad in louisville it was just that there
was this opportunity
there was an excitement yeah and we had
struggled a lot
and we'd been through a lot at that
point um as just
as a family and my mom working
you know three jobs just to keep us in
our house and
you know we were on and off food stamps
for a bit like it was
it was just it was a time and so there
was this
you know um yeah well what did your dad
do
my parents were divorced at that point
and he stayed in louisville
he stayed in louisville yeah oh man
yeah so that was the other thing that
you know we were all
it was it was it is just so wild to
think about
all of that now and how many
people helped us along the way and how
many
like i think about roe now i think about
this holding deal from warner brothers
now i think about
just everything that aligned for all of
us to be here it was
it was um it's really nuts it's kind of
a miracle
it is i mean the chances of survival in
this
sound like we're going to the arctic the
chances of survival here in hollywood
it is like going into the arctic also my
mom was like a single mom she was like
you know i think i'm 40 i turned 40. you
look
by the way not hitting on you i'm just
saying you look fantastic i would have
thought
32 oh michael no you look great is that
now is that really good lighting because
you
you do look great oh god thank you so
much i feel i feel great i feel great
that's good but was it a divorce hard
for you as a kid
yeah divorce is divorce is awful
yeah i don't divorce is awful yeah i
went through it too i went through a
divorce uh in fact i've been through
oh my let's see my sister has been
divorced four times my dad's divorced
twice my mom's divorced
anyway i you know i i get that but how
old were you when they
when they split up 12. well that's got
to be incredibly hard
yeah it was it was i uh
i it's really really hard divorce is
just really hard
um i went through one myself um
a few years ago and i i
i think as a kid um
there was a sort of pressure that maybe
you you want to be i know for me i kind
of wanted to be
everything to both of them i wanted to
help them
that was my feeling was like oh i want
to help
you know you heal and i want to help you
heal and i want to like
everybody's hurting and this yeah it's
just a
it's just a really complicated hard
thing to go through and and
but also i think sometimes
for the best as hard as it is
it's it's not necessarily the unhappy
ending
um oh yeah do you see signs as a 12 year
old because i saw signs when i was a kid
and i was like these people should not
be together
i knew that my parents shouldn't be
together so it didn't
shock me which shocked me as th they
were together as long as they were
so was it was yours shocking or was it
dysfunctional
not shocking at all i remember i think i
remember sort of thinking like
i was surprised it it hadn't happened
yet but i think there was
um like i remember they separated once
when i was about eight and i was
so devastated that i i don't have a ton
of memory from it i just remember like
my brain exploded and i remember just
being so
overwhelmed at that thought and i
actually think my reaction is one of the
reasons that they were like
okay we need to uh we need to maybe we
need to smooth this over for now you
were so devastated that your parents
probably got back together that was
probably the reason
i was probably the reason that they were
unhappy for four
years my god yeah yeah i mean
that's that's tough but they both
supported your endeavors they both
supported you going out to los angeles
and
yeah yeah i think for the most part um
um they were both always i mean i
i always felt that support i mean i did
plays
from the time i was eight years old and
um that was always the one thing and i'm
so grateful i look back on it now i just
think about it's so wild when i think
about
my mom being my age and having like
teenage kids and making a decision to go
to hollywood with them
i it's so wild but um yeah there was
this
feeling that even in
everything my family went through in the
struggles that we had that we
we could still do anything like dream
big
um and and and so i i for that i'm just
incredibly grateful like nothing was off
limit so it's sort of that same thing
yeah do they talk still
were they friends did they do they talk
nothing yeah mine don't either in fact i
always have this fear at my wedding i
i'd have to have two different weddings
because it'd be so uncomfortable
to have them both in the same room and i
really have
i've my therapist is like why are you
talking you're not even in
you're not even a committed relationship
let alone married and you're [ __ ]
worried about your
wedding and your parents being there
what this is anxiety out the ass
i was about to say michael i know
that's not level anxiety i have it too
though i think about things like that
all the time and it's like oh my god
wait this isn't even a real scenario i
don't yeah
do people think because i think you when
i get married it's going to be forever
and i'm not going to meet someone that
i'm not going to be in love with
and then i'm did is is this how you felt
obviously you got divorced but like
most people do get divorced a lot of
people it's not like the 40s where
everybody stays together because
society says you should did you feel
like this is forever this is the is that
how you feel when you get married
yeah it's amazing how things just turn
or turn can turn around so quickly
though
yeah yeah it is that's and
how do you how do you do that what do
you what
is it certain things you just see as you
go and go wow i was wrong this isn't
wasn't as right maybe i had blinders on
whatever it is
what is it i don't i i i kind of
wish i knew
um i guess maybe there are
in hindsight always
i think we can
connect some dots that maybe we didn't
want to
and i'm not just speaking about the in
in
mary i like i would enter any
relationship hoping that it's forever
right
so it's not even just in the marriage
it's sort of
and i think that is probably just a part
of we
you know we our our situation happened
very fast
um but i think it's in the getting to
know process
that you know we all have
i don't know i think we discover you
peel back layers
and and we show our you know
all of our sides i guess and i don't
know
i think you just have to hope that
wherever that person is on their journey
and the tools they have in their toolbox
um you know that you can sync up with
where you are in your journey
and the tools you have in your toolbox
yeah because it's not necessarily
anybody's
i don't know it's sort of uh i don't
know if that totally makes sense but
like
we are just sort of where are where we
are and we just keep growing
and i think in the growth maybe
that's where it can get a little tricky
uh this is very educational for me
because you know i always think about oh
well i ever get married and then
you know i then i i see i jump ahead i'm
like well i gotta you know i gotta
if someone isn't you know if i marry
someone who doesn't have
anything which is fine i usually dig
i've dated a lot of women who
either don't have it together or have it
together it's one of us has it together
i never have it together
but financially you might say you know
how do you ask for a prenup and then i
think
here's how i would do it i would say to
the person
i think we should sign a prenup what
what do you mean oh so you're
no this is because it's not that i'm
worried about me falling out of love
with you
but what if you fall out of love with me
and that's more likely to happen that's
funny i mean
but i look i also think at this point
i mean we're not babies we're not like
you know so i i and we've both wait so
you've been divorced no no i haven't i
haven't been married or anything
oh so you do have a lot of anxiety i do
my foot's shaking as i talk about this i
just think
you know there are realistic and honest
conversations
um that sometimes are not so romantic
but yeah that that needs to be had and i
and i see i understand what you're
saying it's sort of like not putting
some
some weird stamp on the way you think
things are going to go but it's kind of
like
i don't know wanting to wanting to
i don't know wanting to protect yourself
remove i guess it would be removing some
anxiety it's sort of like that we do
these things right we all
to protect ourselves to do that protect
to make us feel safe
yeah and it really has not a lot to do i
mean sometimes it does maybe with the
other person but i feel like sometimes
it doesn't
it mostly doesn't actually have to do
with the other person anything they've
done or whatever it's sort of our
arts well think about this i've worked
my whole life for what i have
now for whatever that is i don't think
it it's it's really
asking that much for someone to say hey
if this doesn't work out which a lot of
marriages don't work out
so if it doesn't i don't want to lose
everything that i've worked so hard for
my whole life because you've decided to
go cheat or you've decided to go
uh you fell out of love with me or my
farts are just enough for you
it's so awful it's heartbreaking
but it's but i understand what you're
saying and it's true
i don't know how you grew up but like
i'm i'm with you i didn't grow up with a
safety net i didn't grow up with some
there's some
trust fund or some other thing back
there that i can lean on or or whatever
that you know it's just me and what i
provide for myself
and the threat of losing that is
is is that's that's all that's a lot
that's everything in a lot of ways like
it's sort of my i'm not saying
on a material level but just on this
sort of emotional
you know you've worked your whole life
and you've built a certain life for
yourself
and i i so i understand that
that feeling was your mom the first
person you went to and you were like
it's over
oh i think so no actually i don't think
so
i think i went to um my friends
uh i have like
these like friends were likes were like
sisters
uh my friend broken rebecca i think i
told first and i remember
i saw uh oh
no i take that back the first person i
told was my brother
was my little brother and how did he
respond
um also a great person in a crisis
uh very very
[Music]
very calm and unprotected it's funny
he's my younger brother but i think he's
always had a bit more of the like
older brother protective thing we're 13
months apart we were raised basically
like twins
so um yeah he was my first phone call
i remember you know marriage feels like
it's something that no matter whose
fault it was
or whatever it's you probably feel like
a bit of a failure
right totally and it's like how do you
deal with that like how do you bounce
back i mean
you're resilient i don't know i think
everybody's
again on have their own experiences in
their own journey
i think for me it made me look at myself
like hard and be like
i had to i've i've had a lot of i've
been very
um what should i say like
tiptoe or timid i i feel like i have
been
very careful and and maybe a bit more
like take your time check in with you
make sure you're not missing anything
like in entering into other
relationships or whatever since
it just made me really look at myself
um you know it's interesting i was in
a relationship pretty much from the time
i was about 22
until the time i was 36. it was like i
had this one relationship in my early
20s i had a long relationship with rojay
who you know
yeah and then i went into this
relationship that i got married
um so the last you know
five years four years um
have have actually been the first like
time that i think i've really been just
with me
yeah how great is that that's a blessing
that in a way
that it happened you're you're young
you're still very young i mean you have
at least
60 years left you live to a hundred
queen elizabeth
is but like honestly aren't you don't
you feel like in a way you're like hey
i'm glad this happened now so i could
find my forever
you know or or maybe if there isn't
forever but you
you took the time all that pain and all
that hurt and all those things of the
introspectiveness is that the right word
i like the word i like it it's just
necessary
i think it's a word um but that probably
was
unbelievably healthy it wasn't in the in
the moment it happened and all this [ __ ]
was going on
but after you got through it you
probably thought oh my god this was
really
[ __ ] great for me yeah yeah for sure
um
i don't think i ever really stopped i've
i worked or and and between working and
between being in
uh relationships uh for
my whole life uh it was a time to
focus on me which i think in a way was
what i was being called to do anyway
yeah so
yeah it was uh
i hope in in for every party involved
it's it's good and that that there is
some sort of
you know this was uh
a learning experience i see why this had
to happen or i
you know what whatever i wish all of all
of it well and everything but i
but i i have been really grateful
to have this time over the last few
years and honestly in this pandemic
to which is probably very weird to say
because it's been such a
horrible time um to to sort of
uh pause yeah and maybe good stuff
enlightening
enlightening it's tough to be alone it's
tough to be i mean you're someone who's
been in relationships most your life and
you know i've been single a lot a long
time i mean i've been in relationships
but
the pandemic as much as you know it's
been terrible for so many
so many people and so really bad
obviously i say that
earnestly but you know for me it's
really been a time like oh tom and
deneen can't come over and hang out with
me
oh rob you know so it's just it's a
tough time but like being alone has
helped me
uh deal with my anxiety deal with a lot
of these things that have been weighing
on me for a long time
and um so it's been good in a bad a bad
in a good way and good in a bad way
but i have had the exact same experience
i mean
yeah having to really maybe deal with
some things that i
have just been i've been working and i
don't need to deal with that and i don't
need to deal with that and it's just
you kind of i feel like i went into like
a forced
like oh yeah okay we gotta look at some
stuff now and deal with it do you clean
out a storage unit i had for 15
for for years and years and years and
years um
why did you keep a storage facility
you're probably paying 200 bucks a month
for that thing
really that's a lot you're spending a
lot of money on storage well i mean
in most of that [ __ ] you probably forgot
about am i right yeah
i think most of that [ __ ] i didn't just
didn't want to deal with or look at it
was like 15 years of life
i mean the storage unit was like the
size of a small apartment in new york it
was crazy
and i have i've i've been living in a
building
uh for the last you know for the last
few years or had been
um and that when when lockdown happened
it it
it felt crazy it's a really fun building
but it was just not
safe and i'm completely paranoid and i i
was like all right so i airbnb for a bit
i've moved like four times during this
last year but
um this isn't my house it's someone
else's house i'm renting but
um but yeah i i i was like why do i
still have this thing
and i hired this like really safe
company to kind of help me go through it
but it was
it was kind of uh that was like a
symbolic i feel like i was like okay
i just i've i've had a lot of [ __ ] in
here i've had a lot of [ __ ]
away with the old away with the old on
with the new
you know new beginnings
inside of you is sponsored by charlie
bear
of got pet products this is an amazing
product that
my dog blanche just dies for and
that's all she's gonna eat right now
she's stubborn once you have the best
your dog deserves the best if you're
making yourself nice meals or you're
giving yourself
nice hearty treats ryan don't you think
your dog deserves the same kind of love
yeah i agree i would hope so you
shouldn't have a dog if you don't feel
that way that's how i feel
the family behind charlie bear is also
behind a human ingredient company that
has been bringing expertise
creative imagination and a passion for
food to people for more than a century
charlie bear treats are wonderful
they're hound
gatos food is wonderful charlie bear has
natural dog treats
they're from our family to your best
friend they're made in the usa
simple ingredients natural ingredients
low calorie
i think they only have like three
calories in these treats pocket friendly
so they don't crumble in your pocket you
know because you want to give your dog
and have them
on hand at all times so you have them in
your pocket and these other treats
three months later you still have crumbs
in your freaking pockets ryan this is
the best product out there i believe
uh you're gonna get high-end dog treats
with charlie bear
and the hound gatos food is just to die
for
look for charlie bear products at your
favorite neighborhood pet stores
and online or visit our website at
www.charliebear.com
that's charlie c-h-a-r-l-e-e-b-e-a-r
for more information shout out to my big
brother adam
uh who works for the company and it's
such an amazing company and all the guys
that work there thank you for being a
sponsor on the show
blanche loves this food and i think
everybody else who gives it a shot
is gonna fall in love with it and i hope
you guys give it a shot just go to
www.charliebear.com
you can also go to
www.houndgatos.houndgatos.com
to get that wonderful food that you see
blanche eating inside of you is brought
to you by
geico geico i mean
you know it says it speaks for itself i
mean you guys i
you know how lazy i can be uh you know i
don't want to go out and get my auto
policy from some place and my home
uh homeowners or renters and shirts from
another place i want to get them all at
one place and i want to go take them to
get them at one place that i know i can
trust that everyone
knows about and that is geico
geico makes it easy they're bundling
policies
to bundle your homeowners or your
renters insurance
along with your auto policy it's a good
thing because we're so
freaking busy with our lives doing our
things and we've got to make things
easier on ourselves so we can enjoy life
more
and geico thank you for that go to geico
folks go to geico
geico geico.com and
get a quote it's so easy and you can see
how much you could save
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com inside of you is
brought to you by
10 000. look when i'm working out if
you're if you guys are trying to train
if you're trying to run if you're trying
to lift
you're trying to change your life for
the good you need to be comfortable
and 10 000 have these seven inch
interval
shorts they have this liner that
prevents chafing
it's tons of features like the silver
ion for odor protection
breathable lightweight shell fabrics
with stretch
optional liner extremely comfortable
i feel like i'm not wearing anything i
almost feel naked in these
tell you the truth there ryan uh they
got perfect summer shirts
lightweight breathable quick drying this
is exactly what you need
to get in shape for the summer to wear
during your workouts
10 000 makes the highest quality best
fitting and most comfortable training
shorts
i have ever worn at the core of 10 000
are three core training shorts built for
all the ways you train
the interval short versatile and great
for hiit
spinning metcons short runs and anything
else you can think of
the foundation short built for
durability for tough gym days and
outdoor adventures
the session short super lightweight
perfect for running yoga and mobility
they've got exactly what you need 10 000
is a direct consumer company no
middleman so you get a premium fabric
trims and techniques that other brands
simply cannot
afford collaborative product development
a team of over 200
athletes tests their gear to ensure the
perfect design
fabric trims and fit pick the short that
is best for your training and then
personalize it with custom liner
and inseam options over 9500 five-star
reviews
free shipping and returns and lifetime
guarantee that's a confident confident
company
10 000 is offering our listeners 15 off
your first purchase go to 10 000 that's
spelled out
10 000 dot cc
and enter code inside to receive 15 off
your first purchase that's
10 000 dot cc
and enter code inside
like you seem like you know you tell me
a lot of these things but you
seem really together like i see that
mom-like figure back in high school
where you're driving your friends around
you're doing this you've all and maybe
that's sort of like
you know what i gather i'm not a
therapist and boy i need one
more than ever but i have one he's great
she's great i have two um but
do you think maybe your whole life
that you've almost been that maternal
figure in a lot of ways to so many
different people and been the strength
that no one's really been the strength
for you and you've never really
collapsed into someone's arms and really
been vulnerable in a way that
you know because i feel like in a lot of
ways i'm always helping everybody else
and then it's me who's kind of like
drained it's me who's kind of like
you know hurting at times and i'm like
[ __ ] man everybody thinks i'm just happy
as a clam all the time and i'm the light
of the party and
whatever and do you get like that do you
feel like that yeah i mean you talk
about like
smiling happy like life of the party i
think uh i think that
that is something i know for me
over time that i feel has become like
there's this expectation that i show up
that way
which at this point in my life i'm sure
as i was younger or whatever i just got
a lot of positive feedback for being
happy and smiley and nice to everybody
and you know
pleasey or whatever but um you know now
i'm really really working i'm trying to
like to drop that because i think what
i'm realizing as i get older yes that
feeling of sort of wanting to be strong
and be there for
for other people um so
i keep it together i still have that
like
maybe there this responsibility feeling
almost of like i can be the safety net
that we didn't have i can be the but
we're all adults
it's that's a lot of that is is like
left over and i can
drop it it's just sort of me getting
used to
not thinking that way um but it's really
hard for me because i feel
an expectation or maybe i've made it up
in my head that i
i come off a certain way i i
i need to be a certain way to maybe be
uh accepted or
whatever that's just the way i'm
expected to show up that it almost
sometimes
is like unless i can show up that way
i'm not going
instead of just showing up where i am
um so that's my [ __ ] that i have to
that i have to drop because nobody's
asking that of me
right and the people of my life you know
now but i think it's part of the reason
like i have a ton of
social media anxiety i have a lot
just like even i talked about sharing
sharing my life or talking
it's and i think a lot of it kind of
comes from that um
yeah i asked james roday i texted dulay
and roday
that rhymed do lay in row day delay and
road day
so i just said hey anything i should say
to maggie i'm interviewing her she goes
no just have fun she probably won't get
too deep or personal
not really her jam but she's awesome
yeah so that's what you just said so he
knows you
and then yeah delay says just seeing
this tell her i love her
i miss her and i can't wait for us to
all suck it again
wow so there was that yeah
i think he was talking about the acting
thing let's just suck it again let's
rock this [ __ ]
we say that it's a thing on cyprus oh it
is
[ __ ] it yeah yeah oh i should know that
i'll suck it again
but uh yeah knows me really well
sorry was that me looking like i i'm
tall for something no do it again
say the second line i'm not doing it
again suck it
no that was just a a
that was an off the cuff one time thing
that i cannot i love that it's so cute
though i got it
oh yeah i know but your anxiety i love
that
day said that wait did you reach out to
tim tim would have omanson i should have
done that
tim is a magnificent guy and uh boy did
you listen to the podcast with us
it was really if you guys haven't
listened to timothy omonson uh
just an amazing man amazing story
amazing actor you should go back and
listen to that he talks about how he had
a stroke and
talk about how he's a very brave man but
also
just really let go and was so pure and
honest and it was beautiful it
really was that was really good do you
you were so great with him
uh well you know what he was it's it's
easy when people like yourself it's just
it's you're easy to talk to it's
we learn a lot from this i i i'm very
interested in this like
you're very good at it well i mean thank
you i i love doing it so
uh i appreciate that so thank you thank
you maggie
um what do you do do you deal with
anxiety
how do you deal with anxiety and what
kind of anxiety do you get what gives
you anxiety
oh everything uh this podcast
this podcast gave you anxiety i turned
down podcast just so you know
i don't do them i've had people reach
out like i
it is a big deal and so i i
i i get very nervous about it so
i i sometimes am but i wanted to do this
and
you you know i've known you for i
haven't seen you in a long long long
time but i've known you for so long and
and i've listened to your podcast and i
you know this was to be honest with you
a little bit of
a like do just do it maggie step into it
maggie you can
you can do this i'm so glad you did just
so you know it is really hard for me to
to talk about myself or to sort of
reveal these things but
um yeah i um
how do i deal with anxiety you know i
think this
pandemic has really helped me i paint
i'm actually in my
uh i i paint um so
so but you mean like just like i don't
take anything
um i haven't done i haven't gone good
for you
painting gets you it's an escape for you
i mean
a complete and total escape i have
years ago a friend of mine came to stay
with me for like a few days and as her
like parting gift when she left she left
me this set of like acrylic paints and
some brushes and a canvas
and i haven't stopped like i just love
painting but i don't share it
it's just for me it's something i kind
of do for love i'm getting a little
better at it now but
see that's great that you do that i i
was having art
nights at my house because the worst
thing in the world i am i'm the worst at
art
there's no question about it i i can't
draw i can't paint i can't
and so i said then this is my therapist
this is perfect for you
it's so you don't have to be great you
go in not knowing you're not going to be
great and you just enjoy it and let go
so fun to me like i'll invite you when
this thing's over
i love it i'm i'm yeah i'm getting i'm
getting more comfortable sort of sharing
it but it really was like a really
private
it was almost like like writing in a
journal for me uh just
my but it became that um and i also
started taking like voice lessons
actually
yeah i i sing i sing my whole life this
is another one of those things like
stage fright things
that happen to me later in life so it's
something i do myself i play a little
guitar i play i sing
but i have really kept it to myself i
know you're in a band yeah we got a jam
we got a paint
and and the thing about these voice
lessons has been really interesting it's
almost been therapeutic beyond just
like getting me singing again it's sort
of he always says
you know you're you're you're not open
like we're trying to open your voice
we're trying to get your voice back so i
have been taking these like voice
lessons and i've been painting
and a lot of this has really really
helped to
uh i don't know maybe it's just a
feeling that you're where i'm working on
something or i'm
i don't know but it has helped me sort
of channel
a lot of that anxiety that i have
well i love this i love this are you is
that a painting behind you that you did
oh this is not mine this is a painting
bob dylan did okay i was like
actually a gift from roday let me see it
let me see it
is it right behind you can i appreciate
it yeah bring it over let's see this is
a gift from
james roday rodriguez correct let's see
if i can get it now
oh [ __ ] no she's going to break some oh
my god that look look behind you that
almost fell
what's it that white thing it's fine
it's paint that's
bob dylan painted that and yeah i can i
see it right now
here i wanna yeah there you go i see it
perfectly
yeah it's a sidewalk cafe in new york
that's great
and when i bought i bought my this house
um
years ago but a house i lived in years
ago and uh
uh i fell in love with this painting i
saw it in london
and um yeah i
i i i didn't buy it but i had told
uh rose about it and then it arrived did
you cry
yeah that's a nice see that's a yeah
that's sweet
good gift um i mean so so when you're on
set do you ever get anxiety with like
lines and things like that and like i
have to be good or you get
you know or that's something you've been
doing for so long that it probably
doesn't affect you like
that's your world it depends i mean it
obviously depends on the scene but
um no i feel like i that is where i kind
of
i my anxiety leaves a little bit wow
it's weird that feels like
i don't know like comfort or something
work i mean obviously depending on the
scene or what we're getting into but
like
yeah i i i love working so much um
that that just it's it's a it's almost
like a comfort zone
wow yeah i think i've always with work
and everything i associate it with
anxiety i have to be anxious i have to
be
so disciplined i have to be great that
it's just like it drives me
crazy to the point where i and i work
so hard that that's what happens so i
really would like to um
eventually let that go more and try to
enjoy it more like i'm trying to enjoy
like
i like like enjoying these podcasts like
being able to put these headphones on
and just
talk to someone and enjoy it and not
think about oh
and all these other external things that
i can't control it's always about
things you can't control that give you
anxiety right absolutely
yeah so you're you're this is
this is great you're very good at this
are you saying i should quit acting
no you're a great actor
what are you saying you've worked
forever well i don't know about that
all right this is called [ __ ] talking
with maggie lawson uh this is from my
patrons you can join patreon at
patreon.com
inside uh it's a wonderful family leanne
wants to ask you this is
how did you begin your work in animal
advocacy how did i begin it um i met
jude well my gosh it goes back to when i
was 16. um i volunteered at the humane
society
even as a kid but uh i met jude my
partner and my foundation in 2014
we both shared this dream of having a
sort of animal i guess a rescue but more
animal
healing uh animal therapy and we had so
many things anyway
and we we just did it we just started
doing it
i mean there's a lot more to that story
of how it sort of came to be what it is
now but
um yeah you could find that on
margaret's blog
on wednesdays no it's not true jason b
was psych really as fun to shoot as it
seems from the outtakes and behind the
scenes stories
really more it was that fun and more it
was the best
the greatest experience
we had so much fun on and off screen we
partied we
played we love each other it's is good
we're not overstating how wonderful of
an experience
we couldn't possibly put into words how
wonderful i could never say that about
anything i've done
although i've loved everything and it's
been amazing what you just said
is like an anomaly to just absolutely oh
my god it's like we're all like
i mean that's seldom that's seldom jane
oh
what was the most useful thing you
learned while working on psych oh gosh
ah oh my gosh useful thing
probably um for what i do
uh it would be learning lines quickly
or um
that's a really tough question i learned
to run on heels
um but yeah i would say it's sort of
thinking on the fly
rodeo was always improving uh there was
always like
line changes that were happening quickly
so i think it just kept us
uh on our toes and yeah i'm
i i can i can memorize and and
absorb faster because of it
wow that's not the greatest reaction
actually that is because that's
but that's pretty useful the fact that
you know that's very useful when you
when you're always on your toes and
things are always changing that would
drive me crazy that things are changing
so much i like to improvise in things
but
uh i don't know i don't know when you're
on a set like that it seems like it
warrants that whole
that whole feel like it just makes sense
it just is a fun
let's try this let's try that but uh
lisa h
what was it like acting with jason
priestley on true calling
your episode was definitely a little
different than others such a great
concept for a show
it was actually a really great concept
for a show
i love jason priestley i haven't seen
him in so long
oh man i have known him from yeah it was
like true calling
and i run into him places then he did
psych um and we still like through
social media have like supported each
other or whatever but i loved it it was
a
it was i didn't do i feel like that was
one of the only dramas like i had done
at that point in my career there weren't
that many and he was so great
so so so so great i i just love him
we got we got along great josh a what
was your experience working with ashton
kutcher on two and a half men and then
again on the ranch
awesome ashton was uh
was so great so great um
he is like super professional um
but also like he was so fun
and so welcoming and i felt i don't know
i
i there was a there was a there was a
that was a crew
like that was a bit of a crew and i um i
felt
very welcomed into it it was really
really nice bob
k what superhero role would you enjoy
taking on
super super woman superwoman
super girl but there should be but
wonder woman why can't they be
superwoman
why i just went to superwoman who's
superwoman isn't it degrading though
why why you think in this time it's
supergirl why can't it be superwoman now
they've never had a superwoman i think
that's what was happening
no wonder woman what the hell um yeah
superwoman
is it tough because i've had this happen
to me and i ask when
siri's like outmatch with jason biggs
when it gets canceled were you guys
really disappointed did
that bother you or it is a heartbreak
that i
it's weird i've had shows get cancelled
and it's like i can see that coming
or or we were done
um this
i i i'm still not over it in fact
jason and i were just texting yesterday
it's it's
it was it was such a it had the same
feeling of like
the way i think psych felt in the
beginning of like lightning striking and
everything worked so it was like okay
this is the first time i've had that
feeling again of like every single thing
here works
i i love him do you know jason i've met
him a couple of times he's really sweet
i just love him so much i loved
everybody on the show so much
and yeah that was a that was a uh
news we got i guess like last may yeah
that was very shocking that was not what
we expected to hear so we i'm i'm i'm
still
still still still healing from this yeah
um you were on smallville
it was a long long time ago yeah we
didn't have anything no we didn't have
any scenes what episode was it do you
remember
no i just remember my character
uh i would kiss boys
and and through kissing them
suck youth the youth out of them so that
i could stay young and they would age
and die
and yeah so it was great great great
character you worked with tom
right yeah i worked with tom i i had
such a good time on that
i had such a good time i had to do this
whole prosthetic thing because i had to
age in the end i i had to age um
and die and i'm claustrophobic that was
one of my
first experiences with something like
that it was it was really
really really intense i remember that it
was just it was so fun though that show
was fun
yeah it was it was a long show long we
had a long run
it was a good run long good run maggie
this has been awesome i really
uh i cherish this time i had with you
and i hope we keep in touch
yes we will we absolutely are art
parties yes our parties and
i wish you the very best and where can
people find you on social oh uh my
instagram
um that i'm trying to get better at
using uh magsloslawson
and my twitter is my name all right
maggie lawson that's it that's all i
have is that what i
thought yeah follow her she's incredible
i know you've probably seen psych if you
haven't even seen the show plus she's
done tons of other [ __ ]
pleasantville smallville um this has
been great thank you again i love you
and um
i'll talk to you soon this is this has
honestly been great great
thank you all right okay wow
bye i really enjoyed that episode
i i enjoy the episodes because i don't
listen to them
um i could do whatever i want with them
you can do whatever you want
that's what you're telling me right but
then you know on the days that were
recording i listened to some stuff and
um again like i said in the beginning
just a likable person and she really
opened up so if you guys really like the
podcast i
encourage you to subscribe again you go
to youtube
and uh go type in inside you with
michael rosenbaum and subscribe to the
podcast that would be great
and uh um also the handles are at inside
you podcast on instagram and
facebook ad inside of you pod on the
twitter
i'm on instagram the michael rosenbaum
you can get great stuff at the inside of
you merch store
like i said just go to the inside of you
online store or the sunspin where you
can get my band stuff you can get the cd
signed we got vinyls coming t-shirts
hats lunch boxes
uh a bunch of great stuff and uh thank
you everybody for coming to the last
stage it
to um watch my band i really appreciate
that i love playing music for you guys
and i love doing this podcast so thank
you cumulus thank you ryan thank you
bryce it's been a real treat and my
patrons
those patrons who give back to the
podcast they they don't even need to
just subscribing is enough but they
give a little more by going to
patreon.com inside you becoming a patron
and there's all sorts of tears and
behind the scenes and q and a's and you
get to ask me questions and the guest
questions and you get merch and
uh it's a lot of fun so thank you for
that right now we're gonna
get right into it and uh we're gonna
shout the names out
ryan let's shout the names out to all
the top
patrons these are the top patrons that
give the most
and uh they are very loved and
very um i'm very appreciative of them
right let's see if ryan remembers any of
these nancy d
mary b f trisha what
f sarah s v
v little lisa yukiko jill
e brian h lauren g nico
p robin s jerry w
robert b jason w apophia and kristen k
amelia o allison oh l lucas m raj
c we got joshua d we got emily s cjp
samantha m jennifer and jackie p stacy l
carlyache carly s jen s jamal f
janelle b tablet the 272 not to be
confused with chad with the 273
ashley ryan kimberly e mike e l don
supremo dan 99 more
ramira santiago m sarah f's chad w
leanne p
ray a maya p maddie s kendrick f ashley
e
shannon d matt w belinda carlisle no
n belinda n james r chris h dave h
samantha s spiderman chase sheila
easton sheila g i know it's jeep
ray h tabitha t tom and suzanne b
liliana a michelle k marcus w
hannah b michael s italia m andrew t
betsy d claire m liz j laura l
chad l rochelle or rachel nathan e
and here's the last last of them taylor
k marion meg
k janelle p trav l dan l diane r
oh jeddah lorraine g corey m veronica
k stevie big stevie w kendall t carol d
sandy m angel m eric c rhiannon c
stephen m cory k super sam emily c
sherry s coleman g
david c michelle a matt w liz l jeremy c
andy t
and chris e those are the wonderful
lovely patreons
um thank you for um being my top tier
patrons
um thank you for listening to the show
today uh we've got great shows coming up
we really sincerely do
um a lot in the can and uh a lot of
really good information
a lot of um people opening up about
their darkest stuff and uh you know i
like that so
uh thank you uh bryce ryan yay for
myself michael roosevelt you're in the
hollywood hills california california
myself ryan t is over here in the
hollywood council
yeah we wave to the camera up there
right up there how are you
and uh you guys thank you so much just
please be good to yourselves
learn to appreciate yourselves like
yourselves
and be good to others and uh thank you
for allowing me to be inside each and
every one of you
so all right i really appreciate you
make sure you subscribe
damn it